Singapour compte un nombre infini de
règles de la vie quotidienne qu'il faut
connaître par cœur sous peine d'être
sévèrement puni
[Musique]
à Singapour si tu jettes un déchet par
terre tu risques une grosse amende ça te
coûtera 340 euros et même si tu craches
tu auras une grosse amende
une vraie Rockstar
monsieur prof ne peut pas se balader
dans Toulouse sans être abordé par des
jeunes femmes d'un prof d'anglais sur
Instagram et Tik Tok il poste depuis
plus d'un an de courtes vidéos
pédagogiques et drôles
comment le surnomme et surtout connu
pour ses prises de position anti-vax
complotistes il avait choqué l'Amérique
avec cette comparaison entre la
vaccination obligatoire et le régime
nazi même dans l'Allemagne d'Hitler vous
pouviez fuir ensuite en traversant les
Alpes vous pouviez vous cacher dans un
grenier comme Anne Frank avait fait tu
as le droit d'avoir un chien mais tu
n'as pas le droit d'avoir un chat c'est
interdit par la loi
de marcher tout nu même chez toi
si un voisin te voit te dénonce tu peux
avoir une amende de 1500 euros et 3 mois
de prison
c'est considéré comme un attentat à la
pudeur
on a cette place on peut s'allonger côte
à côte c'est pas un problème c'est juste
pour se réchauffer j'ai pas de faire un
câlin t'en fais pas ouais je sais
allez c'est une question de survie
ça va pas vraiment non
je refuse de faire un câlin à un autre
homme jamais de la vie sa dernière
théorie fumeuse s'il y a davantage
d'adolescents transgenres c'est à cause
de l'eau qu'il boivent il y a de
l'atrazine dans notre eau si vous mettez
de la traze en laboratoire dans un
réservoir en pleine grenouille cela
castrera chimiquement et féminisera de
force toutes les grenouilles qui s'y
trouvent à Paris aujourd'hui avait lieu
la marge des fiertés des milliers de
personnes ont défilé aux couleurs du
drapeau arc-en-ciel pour défendre les
droits des LGBT un cortège sans charent
cette année par souci écologique plus de
40 ans que cette manifestation existe un
défilé qui au fil des années aura permis
de faire évoluer certaines mentalités
c'est soit nous allons nous en canailler
un peu comme un label époque non j'adore
alors je vous souhaite une merveilleuse
soirée en notre compagnie regardez ça
c'est des images générées par une
intelligence artificielle à qui on a
demandé de faire une synthèse du corps
parfait selon les réseaux sociaux les
tout ça est hyper caricatural il est des
hommes
ils sont tous bodybuildés les femmes
aussi je suis vraiment faire une pêche
alors en fait moi depuis tout petit
j'étais lissé par mon papa donc moi je
suis originaire d'Aix-les-Bains la plus
belle ville de sa voix et d'autres
cerveau aussi et donc alors vous pêchez
quoi du coup moi je pêche de tout je
pêche essentiellement je pêche le l'eau
douce donc je pêche du brochet du
carnassier de la perche du cendre en
rivière je pêche de beaucoup de truites
et sinon quand je vais en vacances je
pêche beaucoup de de ton sur tous les
tons
[Musique]
5 lettres
avec ma langue française
je vous French Kiss avec la langue
Molière ça vous excite quand je vous
baise dans l'oreille votre langue est
ainsi mis dans ton OK
[Musique]
le clitoris le clic-cli le bambeau le
friperie le bouton à chacun son petit
nom pour le clitoris c'est
de la dynamique il nous rend tous
hystérique
j'aime beaucoup retrouver talita ma
tortue aujourd'hui je le fais goûter un
haricot vert et ça l'a rendu
complètement joyeuse me suivez partout
il ne voulait plus me quitter le
chocolat je pense
on entend dire qu'il faut pas donner de
chocolat alors pourquoi je on sait que
le chocolat on peut pas le donner à
Philippe
une chèvre et la chèvre parce que sur la
mets la Mélanie non le truc là qui
brille je crois que c'était Ségur
c'était si
et on a la chaîne ne voulait pas venir
donc moi je dis appeler professeur clan
venez et tout donc une moto va chercher
[Musique]
cours de chant de recherche de vibrato
là on était plus ou moins bas donc on a
essayé de monter la note et là on est
arrivé je crois pendant ce temps là moi
je fais les missions tac tac et clan il
a voulu calmer la chèvre et la calmé
mais définitivement
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est horrible
voilà sur le côté et vous pouvez appuyer
l'intérieur du jongle
peut-être c'est plus confortable pour
vous choisissez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment de toute façon
allez Fred l'équipe des moutons elle n'a
pas vraiment l'air impressionné
regardez ça s'est passé hier lors des
Championnats d'Europe d'athlétisme en
Pologne la lanceuse de poids belge bunko
a dû s'improviser spécialiste du 100
mètres pour remplacer au pied levés sa
compatriote qui avait déclaré forfait
seul manières d'éviter à la Belgique la
discalification résultat vous le voyez
pas très glorieux mais l'essentiel est
assuré et l'athlète elle-même l'a pris
avec beaucoup d'humour